un sencillo código qr que certifique la
vacunación algo sencillo de conseguir
para los franceses vacunados en
territorio nacional pero un dolor de
cabeza para los expatriados vacunados en
el extranjero esta realidad ha cambiado
a partir de esta semana los franceses
que viven fuera de francia y se
vacunaron con vacunas aprobadas en la
unión europea o sus equivalentes podrán
enviar por correo electrónico su
comprobante de vacunación para recibir
su código qr a partir del 9 de agosto
este código será obligatorio para
acceder a muchos lugares tras la entrada
en vigor del pase sanitario muchos
franceses han salido a la calle por
considerar que coarta las libertades ya
estoy aquí por nuestras libertades
nuestras libertades fundamentales que
son el derecho a decidir y especialmente
en aquello que concierne a nuestra salud
elegir ser vacunado o no los expatriados
se quejaban también que era muy
complicado conseguirlo tras haber sido
vacunados en el exterior sin embargo
aquellos inoculados con una vacuna no
homologada por la unión europea seguirán
sin tener una solución
que para muchos sería aceptar todas las
vacunas validadas por la organización
mundial de la salud por el momento el
gobierno no se ha pronunciado al
respecto